alors on a évidemment toujours ce flux
de sucre qui nous amène des entrées
maritimes donc Languedoc-Roussillon
ce sera vraiment le soleil qui va
s'imposer au fur et à mesure
[Rires]
même le café en terrasse commence à
avoir un goût amer je suis d'adepte de
bonnes chaleurs régionales mais c'est
vrai que
c'est préoccupant c'est surtout la durée
qui est préoccupante plus que
l'intensité des températures sa nature
qui commande il ne peut pas la dominer
la nature il peut influencer il peut
faire des statistiques des estimations
mais à part ça il fait rien d'autre
c'est le réchauffement climatique
donc on regarde les températures parce
que ça c'est pas drôle du tout en fait
les températures que nous avons ce matin
ce sont
maintenant l'après-midi à cette période
de l'année normalement le matin on
devrait avoir une moyenne de 8 degrés le
matin donc autant vous dire qu'on est
quand même très loin et puis cet
après-midi et bien au pire au pied des
trop content
non il y a plus que la Bretagne il y a
plus que la Bretonne ça veut dire qu'on
va être obligé de manger des galettes
toute notre vie puis moi j'aime pas le
chuchen je connais que deux chansons de
Nolwenn
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire Jennifer
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire depuis le mois
de mai la sécheresse s'aggrave et il
faut à tout prix éviter les coupures
d'eau ici chacun a son astuce pour
respecter les restrictions quand je fais
couler l'eau de ma douche avant qu'elle
devienne chaude je remplis un petit
arrosoir
avec lequel après je vais arroser mes
fleurs dès le lever du jour alors qu'ils
étaient encore en train de constater
l'ampleur des dégâts ils ont vu arriver
plus de 80 fourgonnettes de soi-disant
couvreur venus proposer leur service
auprès des sinistrés il prétendait être
mandatés par la mairie ou par des
assureurs ce qui était faux et il
proposait d'établir des devis moyennant
un acompte en espèces 1300 euros c'est
ce qu'ils ont réclamé à une vieille dame
heureusement pour elle les gendarmes
sont intervenus juste à temps mais nous
on essaie de faire avancer les on en a
traité presque 30 000 mesdames et
messieurs durant ces 20 dernières années
avec un taux de 80% de réussite donc
laissez-nous faire le boulot on essaie
de le faire vraiment le buzz laissez ça
au à des petits journaux qui essaient de
faire du sensationnalisme
[Musique]
tout le monde
et puis politique toujours un troisième
49.3 en une semaine hier à l'Assemblée
nationale Elisabeth borne a de nouveau
eurocourt à cet article de la
Constitution cette fois sur l'ensemble
du projet de budget 2023 de la sécurité
sociale un dispositif qui permet une
adoption sans vote en première lecture
sauf en cas de motion de censure
déposées par l'opposition et adoptée
il passe en force le tyran
le tyran c'est bon mais il y a des bas
sur ces notions de sangsues de sur ses
motions pardon de censure au sein de la
nupes tout ça ne faut désormais chez
Emmanuel Macron à l'image de cette
colère surjouée à laquelle il ne
paraissait pas croire lui-même quand il
dénonça la collusion de la France
insoumise et du rassemblement national
qui peut croire en France que Marine Le
Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon avance main
dans la main pardon les gens n'ont pas
être fatigués c'est la démocratie vous
voulez quoi une dictature vous voulez
qu'on obéisse au président de la
République bien sûr que non
et à changer la vie des gens
radicalement sur notre plateau manuel
Macron ne voit pas de lien entre la
délinquance et l'immigration le réel
n'existe pas l'Élysée est une forteresse
qui a mordit les bruits de la ville le
Président est ailleurs il pense déjà son
bilan il cherche un successeur il est
devant une maison en ruine et il
explique qu'on peut encore dîner dans le
salon
[Musique]
pas de langue de bois non
parler on finira dans les Alpes le Tour
de France
même quand on a mal aux fesses on essaie
de gagner la course je crois que c'est
l'adage du jour il faut faire comme les
anciens faisaient ils mettent une
escalope dans le fond du cuissard bien
sûr on a abandonné cette si bonne
transition
qui disent qu'il faut pas faire c'est
tout pour les laisser faire
ça des fois parce que ces gens-là ne
seront pas demain gouvernés ensemble ils
se sont tous écrits qu'il fallait faire
barrage d'un à l'autre puis un côté de
son moral
enfin il le répète deux fois ce qui me
met en colère parler c'est ridicule là
il est franchement là il est ridicule il
paraît qu'en souriant et en provocation
vous avez dit à votre femme Martine je
vivrai jusqu'à 100 ans et je mourrai
dans les bras d'une jeune de 18 ans
laisse-moi fait vivre
peut-être que la jeune femme je la
verrai pas mais j'irai peut-être à 100
ans mais c'est tout le bien qu'on vous
j'avais une voisine à la campagne
autrefois qui disait c'est pas la peine
d'être si intelligent pour être si bête
une belle réflexion
à demain